Pete are you still coming to us from
mom's basement in the quarantine live
from mom's basement how is that I love
it I love having my family here I feel
very lucky yeah so guys the first thing
I want to ask you of course I've seen
train wrecks such a great movie is it
true that Amy Schumer is responsible for
the the origin of this partnership she
is you know we were casting trainwreck
and sitting around one day with our
YouTube open and I said who should I
know that's funny that I don't know and
the first person she said was Pete and
then we went on YouTube and watched one
of his sets and he was crazy funny and
crazy funny and twenty years old I
started doing stand-up when I was around
that age and I was not funny at all none
of us were funny as he was at that age
and then he did a cameo in trainwreck
and the next day he called Pete and he
said I just called Lorne Michaels and
said you should be in the cast of
Saturday Night Live and then he
auditioned and got it so it's all Amy
should be commissioned and Pete here you
are we're doing a junket for this movie
that you have played such a huge part in
on so many levels
I love that you're still in mom's
basement I love that you have a Swiffer
behind you you're keeping it clean down
there
yeah we're keeping it clean my mom likes
to keep it very nice and clean down yeah
don't worry mom I know your daughter got
smart and went to college and abandoned
us but I'm still here
I'm gonna be here forever yeah I saw
that you said this movie was a love
letter to your mom and that was so
beautiful to me I'm wondering if she's
seen it at what she thinks of it and if
you feel you achieve that um yeah my mom
seen it it's a love letter to pretty
much my whole family my mom's sister and
my dad and she saw it at the screening
and she really loved it and it really
meant a lot to me and I think we we made
her proud I love you know you guys have
Jed your daughter in the movie
Pete your grandpa how much fun was it
having all those family and friends on
set and did Grandpa learn his lines well
was he a good cast member grandpa killed
it he he loved it he is a big fan of
movies and he's the guy who got me into
movies we used to make a lot of films at
home so you know just to be able to put
him into something you know really
really was awful Jed how was it
directing your daughter again you know
it was really fun I hadn't directed
Maude since this is 40 which was eight
years ago yeah so I feel like in the
past when we made a movie she was so
little that I wasn't really directing
her I was just manipulating her and
tricking her and forcing her to fight
with Paul and Leslie or fight with her
sister and this was really fun because
she's been working on euphoria and that
Ryan Murphy show Hollywood and she came
in as a real master of her craft she was
really funny and it was great watching
her yell at Pete did you have any any
nerves in those scenes or did you just
say come at me yell at me as much as you
want Maude Maude such a great actress
she just really brought it and we really
had I think a great relationship on
screen and off screen so I think she
really crushed it I mean I also saw you
said that you hoped this movie would be
healing and I gotta tell you I'm a I
lost my dad when I was younger too so I
was really watching this in a very
personal way and wondering really for
you how healing it was for you
ultimately um I think having to you know
deal with that sort of thing at such a
great scale really helped me heal you
know it really made me think that I
could put this behind me now because you
know we like went through it all
together so I really feel a lot better
and I hope some other people can also
relate to that
Kotetsu what are those numbers on your
arm oh that's the date my dad died he
was a fireman
died in a fire 17 years ago oh my god
I'm so sorry
okay it's fine knock knock who's there
now your dad and I think Jed you said
you thought people might understand Pete
better watching this movie uh Pete do
you do you feel better and do you want
that to happen yes I feel like I'm I
don't know like I I kind of feel a
little bit misunderstood and I feel like
you know it's a really tricky situation
but I think what John and I and Dame
Cyrus did I think hopefully it'll you
know get that point across better I
think I was really struck watching it
because it really drove home to me you
know there's grief and there's things we
deal with and then there's also mental
health and and kind of how those things
are separate but intertwined and how
much that can be to deal with so what
what did you want to maybe say to people
or what advice would you have for people
who you feel like take something away
from this movie what do you want them to
maybe take away from it so they can feel
stronger - I'm just that you know if
you're struggling you're not the only
one and you know a lot of people
struggle and I think you know watching
Scott go through this and find a way to
heal you know through a tragedy is you
know important and we don't see enough
of that so I think I think we did a good
job of that yeah what do you do having
having grown having healed from a lot of
what you've dealt with what do you do
now if you do start to feel a little
lost or feel in a dark place what kind
of help grounds you I am in therapy lots
of therapy my therapists are really on
the ball and I'm very lucky to have them
in my lives and you know just just I I
recommend that everybody go to therapy I
think it helps for people to have that
discussion now especially I don't know
if our world's ever been quite so
volatile and coming off of three months
cooped up yeah you know I appreciate you
saying that and I don't know how this
has affected both of you how are you
both with the state of our world and and
being in a basement and in-home right
now I think that we're you know we're
hanging in there definitely uh you know
a very complicated time and you know
we're hopeful that some real change
happens as a result of all this because
that's the most important thing that
things do change
yeah um Pete I wondered there's a line
in here I know this is
semi-autobiographical someone tells you
I feel bad that you don't think you're
great
have either of you ever had a girlfriend
really say that to you was that line for
real life well yeah I had a girl say to
me once while breaking up with me one
day you're gonna realize how little you
know right now I still don't know what
she's talking about hey what about you
yeah I think I've had you know I've been
fortunate enough to have some great
relationships and you know honesty is
always really important and I actually
did have a girl say that to me yeah and
did you did you believe it I still don't
understand what she's talking about
I've been dating someone for a little
while on them the first guy you date in
17 years is a fireman just like that you
don't think that's weird
Pete by the way I wanted to ask you a
you kind of flip out when mom dates
somebody new in this movie was that for
real life have you allowed for mom to
date new people or are you very
protective um I kind of I've never seen
my mom date before that was something we
you know we wrote for the movie but I
always encouraged her to date but she's
so particular about me and my sister and
taking care of us that we made this
movie as a way to be like you know it
would be okay if you got yourself out
there and made yourself happy oh so this
isn't just a love letter this is saying
mom find some love yeah get out there
yet I wondered what um what do you think
your dad would think about the fact that
you're sitting here talking about your
movie that you made I think he would get
a kick out of it I think he'd be really
proud and he would wonder why he wasn't
in the movie
mrs. Davidson before Pete says anything
I just like to say that I'm sorry
because I've only known him a week but I
can only imagine
thanks reese witherspoon last questions
for UI urine you're in a movie now your
main character in a movie so I gotta ask
how much longer do you see yourself at
SNL does this signal a jump in to mostly
filmmaking for you I will be there as
long as they allow me to be I think I'm
very lucky to have be on that show and
I'm really lucky to have more on
Michaels is you know not only a mentor
and a boss but a friend and you know I
I'm I'll be there as long as they allow
it have you screamed this for any of
them gotten their feedback on it I
haven't heard back yet from anybody yet
but I think we send out the screeners
this week so I'm really looking forward
to that
um and Jed I wanted to ask you you know
we touched on this but you're somebody
who always voices his opinion and speaks
up for people if people do have a hard
time knowing what to do in this moment
that we're having what do you say to
them about how to enter the conversation
or listen what's your advice well
certainly you should get educated I you
know was stressed this morning I woke up
at 4:00 a.m. and I just read and watch
videos for several hours and I think
there's a lot of things that people
could learn a lot more about and then I
would get educated about voting everyone
needs to register to vote young people
voted the rate of about 46% and you know
people have a lot of power if they
register and get those and get those I
love that well I'm glad you're keeping
the basement just a spiffy clean down
there it looks great and thank you both
this movie was really really wonderful I
really appreciated it it made me laugh
and cry and all the things so thank you
both guys great work thank you very much
appreciate it
[Music]